dangerous smoke from wildfires in Canada
choking out America and orange Haze
blanketing the Skies over a dozen states
and causing air quality alerts from
Minnesota to as far south as the
Carolinas but it is the most hazardous
right here in New York City which is
experiencing its worst air quality and
recorded history the smoke forcing the
FAA to shut down multiple airports
during the day and Major League Baseball
has postponed tonight's Yankees White
Sox game due to the air quality the
city's mayor is warning vulnerable
residents to stay inside
New Yorkers must take precaution we
recommend vulnerable New Yorkers stay
inside
and all New Yorkers should limit outdoor
activity to the greatest extent possible
this is not the day to train for a
marathon or to do an outside event with
your children stay inside close windows
and doors and use air purifiers
and while Americans choke on the smoke
the far left smells an opportunity
a AOC thinks this is a great time to
push your green New Deal she says that
we must quote adapt Our Food Systems
energy grids infrastructure and health
care to prepare for what's to come other
Democrats are pumping up climate
hysteria and bringing back you guessed
it Mass insanity
I wear my mask in solidarity climate
change is not a host
we're not only seeing the haze from
these fires we're also feeling it in our
very own lungs the work to protect our
climate is far from over and we're
dangerously behind it's only getting
worse but this is why the president has
made climate change a priority this is
why he's taking the aggressive actions
that he's taking historic actions
so what are our friends in Canada doing
about this their prime minister Justin
Trudeau is not issuing an apology but he
does seem worried about the kids
people across the country are being
affected we're seeing vulnerable people
at risk outdoor events canceled kids
having to be kept inside at recess
I can't help but think
my conversation with Liam yesterday to
conversations with my own kids the past
few years
have been challenging for kids
whether it was through the pandemic
whether it was readjusting to school
whether it's now dealing with file
wildfires
you know Dana I think it's interesting
you know you hear from the left you know
where they're kind of throwing us back
to the pandemic and all that but look
the mayor of New York City is asking
Millions to stay indoors I mean there's
talking about whatever it is going
directly into our bloodstreams and yet
we haven't heard of people from
President Biden and we don't even know
if the White House has spoken with
Canada they might have called a lid
I don't know there might be a lid on the
White House to protect them from the
smoke a few things first of all Canada
has done something that many have not
been able to do and that is United
Americans and anger against Canadian our
Northern neighbor and we thank them for
that
um just kidding about a week or two ago
my sister in Denver was complaining that
they hadn't been able to see the
mountains and had been very hazy and
Smoky there for about a week or two and
I remember as a kid this would happen
occasionally the difference here is that
these are wildfires in Canada and then
those wind pattern is sending it down
here so where were AOC Schumer anybody
else talking about anybody care about
the West that's been dealing with this
for a long time they don't they don't
care about it until it hits here did
they even know there were wildfires in
Canada and Canada is experiencing really
bad wildfires on their public lands okay
and we have a similar problem and it has
to do with Forest management the Biden
Administration has policies that are in
direct conflict with one another the
first is that they say they want to
restore and preserve old growth and
mature Forest on the other hand the
Department of Agriculture has declared a
wildfire crisis and they're using money
from the infrastructure bill in the ira
in order to deal with large swaths of
forest lands where you do not have this
problem is on privately owned land
because people who own their own land
figure out a way to keep it a little bit
more intact when wildfires can occur
naturally of course but if you are
actively managing your Forest then you
can prevent some of these things the
left has never wanted to do that let's
say that you have a project where you
want to make sure that this old growth
forest that you deal with the underbrush
but one of the things that happens is
the environmentalists will throw every
single thing that they have in its way
to prevent you from actually doing that
and then what do you have you have a
problem that not just Rural America that
is dealing with this now but because we
have built so far into it's called the
wui the wildlife wild Urban interface
yeah
then you have more and more people being
affected by it I actually worked on the
healthy Forest legislation so it's all
coming back to me and I will shut up now
I love that bill Dana the point that
Dana makes is a great point and it has
to do with Forest management and we
first started talking about this when
there were wildfires in California and
Gavin Newsom was blaming everything but
you know any kind of forest management
and yet we're at a point now when I
think uh 49 of Americans believe climate
change is caused mostly by human actions
the lowest reported apparently in many
years so why are Democrats why do they
keep pushing climate change over
something that could have been prevented
well it's good to be back around the
table and being this conversation uh
look I think it's hard to I don't I
don't I think the politics of this can
go it probably goes both ways and I
don't disagree the forest management
issue is one that Democrats probably and
Republicans uh if you're in the majority
in the house perhaps a forest management
bill that Dana referenced should be
perhaps one of the priorities we can and
we can and should debate uh what causes
these occurrences I have an opinion a
theory of the case that uh some of this
a lot of this is man-made but I I'm open
to the debate but what is harder to
debate uh is the frequency the
increasing frequency of these
occurrences and what's even even harder
to debate about that is that it's it's
clear that our climate is changing for
some set of reasons few facts Dana
pointed out things that have happened
out west for a while the West is running
out of water it's scarcer than it's been
fires are seemingly everyday occurrences
out west it's hard to buy home insurance
in Florida because insurance companies
are reluctant to sell home insurance
unless at a prohibably high price
because of because of the frequency
increasing frequency of hurricanes
what's happened here in Canada I hope
that they learn from this it's
disconcerting and concerning on other
levels because this is the beginning of
their their Wildfire season this thing
is going to supposedly according to the
meteorologist will last deeper into July
and maybe even early August so this may
unfortunately we're dealing with today
and yesterday we could find ourselves
dealing with it more and more I just
wish whatever the answers are take the
politics out of it we need more money
for Forest management with policies are
in conflict with one another the
Congress and the center to get together
and figure this out because what we've
experienced here today in New York uh
has been has been bad you know Jesse one
of the things that that I was reminded
of when I realized that we were inhaling
the air from the fires in Canada was
something that I always reference and
that is that we shut down coal plants
here and they're building them over in
China you know uh in multiples to create
these lithium batteries we all breed the
same air and so this idea that we have
to stop building cold plants here isn't
that nothing more than virtue signaling
before we get started I just want to
acknowledge How brave all of us are for
showing up to work today in this city we
are working under hazardous air quality
conditions
this City's air quality is worse than it
was on 9 11. what did we do we came into
the building to put on a show for you
America some people have called us
firefighters I don't know if I'd go that
far but I understand where you're coming
from
yesterday when I looked upstairs and I
saw the smog and I thought it was
because of the free crack pipes the
mayor was handing out then I found out
it was our neighbors so we got the
Neighbors in the South giving us
migrants the Neighbors in the north
they're giving us smoke bombs
are you kidding me right now Canada I
mean are you kidding me not a single
word not an apology nothing
and we find out the combination is from
campers in Canada who don't know how to
put out a campfire and lightning strikes
now I'm not asking Trudeau to apologize
for the lightning strikes but for the
Reckless campers I'm going to have to
demand an apology I saw a woman coming
into work today she took off her mask
and lit a cigarette
hahaha
I'm just happy my marathon training can
resume tomorrow because we got a big
race coming up
I also want to note something to all of
you climate crazies
New England's dark day it occurred in
1780. this was when the entire area of
New England went pitch black around noon
people were lighting candles it was
because of forest fires in Canada we did
not have the internal combustion engine
in 1780 so this stuff just happens
fires in the forest are actually less
prevalent is this the apocalypse are we
looking for the signs we had a UFO
situation the other day
I don't know we had an eclipse remember
Trump was looking up there with the
stupid goggles
I found a frog in my pool yeah oh my god
did we had a pandemic
you have a pool there are a lot of
suspicious things how about the witches
in Canada that were feasting on the dear
flesh under the Moonlight which ones you
didn't see Jesse Waters prime time last
night no I didn't okay I'm gonna go to
you Greg he really wants that 8 PM slot
yeah started in Ukraine yeah
all right uh all right Greg you know uh
can we does it matter what the question
is no it doesn't the WNBA the WNBA
which plays indoors
suspended their games you know why
there's a good reason they were worried
about the health of their fan
[Laughter]
already the media is blaming climate
change
ABC is connecting it to Climate Change
USA Today asked if the fires were
actually caused by climate change and
Harold you're right your intuition is
that it's man-made 90 percent of all
wildfires are started by humans
campfires left unattended burning of
debris discarded cigarettes uh equipment
malfunctions and get this and you'll
know and a lot of people in California
know this concerning the homeless one in
four wildfires are caused by arson
people start them because they're
mentally ill uh and you're right we've
abdicated uh real Forest management and
so there's a lot more to burn and that's
why insurance companies are leaving
California I love the haze it's the best
thing to come from Canada since Jason
Priestly first it's really hard to see
what's going on on the street and when
you live in New York that's a good thing
that's a good thing got your junkie
shooting up you got the homeless
defecating you got kill me just
hitchhiking all of that is obscured by
that surreal magnificent Haze and even
better the air is so thick it actually
can slow down bullets so it helps when
you're on the street and caught in a
crossfire which is now often you're
right about the apocalypse New York City
needed needed an Airborne environment to
match its current state of despair you
already have it's like the road warrior
you already got the marauding gangs the
deranged Street Maniacs the filthy
streets you just needed the toxic icing
on this crusty cadaverous cake I mean
this is as hazy as Harold's dorm room in
college
what is he trying to say fake news
you know you know what they said they
said it was like if you're out there for
an hour it's like smoking six cigarettes
so I was thinking of smoking one
cigarette and then being ahead of the
game
oh no never hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else